نشد هذه الخيم التي رفعت على عجل منذ
الامس في هذه المنطقه هذه المحل الذي نحن
به هو يضم عدد كبير من المئات من
المتطوعين والمتطوعات الذين اتوا من خارج
هذه المدينه بالاضافه ايضا الى بعض الفرق
التي اتت من دول عربيه نصبت لها اخيه
ومراكز تنطلق منها الى عمليات الاغاثه
المخيف او الخطير الذي يصادف يصادفنا على
العمل على الارض او ايضا بالنسبه الى
المواطنين الاتراك هي الارتدادات للزلزال
فعند الساعه العاشره ليلا كانت اخر عمليه
ارتدال شعرنا بها تقريبا وصلت الى 4.5 الى
خمسه في هذه المنطقه وايضا شعرنا ان الارض
تهتز خاصه في المناطق الخاليه لان في
المناطق بهو الخارجيه اما اذا ذهبت معك
الان الى الصوره لربما يمكن ان اخذ
او اخر حركه الشاحنات هنالك المئات من
الشاحنات والعشارات التي تاتي طيله الليل
وهي تصل الى هنا من المناطق الاخرى او
ايضا من الدول الى المطارات ثم بعد ذلك
الى هذه المدينه وهي تقوم بعمليه فراغ هذه
المواد التي هي متشعبه ومتنوعه الجل
الاكبر او الهم الاساسي للمواطن التركي
الان كان ان يحصل على مبيت وهذا ما رايناه
بام العين او استطيع قال انه تمت السيطره
عليه عندما يستطيع هذا المواطن ان يذهب
الى متر ونصف او عرض فقط نصف متر في
المخيمات او على جوانب الطرقات او حتى
ايضا في السيارات يعني لو كان امكن
بالسياره الى تلك السياره الان التي قربنا
هي الان فيها عائله ولولا الخصوصيه لكننا
ذهبنا اليها الرجل ووالده وزوجته هي تقف
في هي تنام في ايضا الجهه الخلفيه كما
ايضا
لهم محمود لماذا اختاروا البقاء في هذه
السياره من محمود كنت تسمعني نحن بها ايضا
مطعم خصص على عجل وهو يستقبل يوميا الالاف
من المواطنين الطرق والاكراد
محمود محمود ان كنت تسمعني تسمعني نعم
يعني هذه الاسره التي يعني نقلت صورتها
الان قبل قليل على الهواء مباشره لماذا هي
موجوده في هذه السياره الا تتوفر لهم
اماكن امنه اماكن دافع للبقاء فيها
ليس هنالك من اماكن دافئه وليس هنالك من
اماكن امنه ليس هنالك من كهرباء ولا غاز
ولا ايضا انترنت وليس هنالك حتى الخبز غير
موجود هو ياتي يؤتى به من المحافظات
الاخرى وعليه من وجد في سيارته مامنا هذه
السياره هي عنوان لمئات من السيارات التي
هي على الطرقات او هي في جوانب الشوارع
المحزن او ايضا المفكي ان تشاهد عائلات هي
هي تسعى في هذه المنطقه في هذه المحله الى
الحصول الى على احرام او على وساده او على
بطانيه وهو بالوقت ذاته يقف امام بنيته في
المقرب الاخر وكل اغراضه المنزليه هي
موجوده في البنايه ولكنه لا يمكن له ان
يصعد الى هذه البنايه لان جل الاب في هذه
المدينه هي متصدعه خطيره جدا